so what do you want me to give the
reveal oh yeah how much time do we have
left
what reveal he said he has to be in a
review oh yeah yes yes all you need
right
yeah that's a go do belong we're gonna
work done oh I didn't want to be done no
I just want want to be done yet
I just wanted to double-check I would
let's go into Italy I want have a couple
more questions yeah about your life and
then we'll go into that reveal okay
right if this reveal look out to be good
now is it good too much so um
oh so I just want to talk about Johnny
has a beautiful daughter yeah and when I
met you I never thought that you would
ever have kids I didn't want kids I know
I never thought that it would he would
be the last person to have kids I was
like I'm not and you were like a [ __ ]
machine back then yeah this is what you
well you know I want to talk about how
is that possible if I look like a three
cricket in a raccoon because I was that
possibly I'll tell you how it's possible
back then though there was cuz you were
you know I was younger Bobby not only
that so it's like I know but here's the
thing when I was young all I wanted to
see was a dude that was a minority
that's more like me you reminded me of
me in the sense of that you know I grew
up you had a lot your white friends
growing up yeah - yeah
we were friends grew up in America we
have that sensibility and when I watched
you you know I used to open from Mencia
and I you know I knew George and Paul
Rodriguez all those guys yeah when I was
a young guy but you to me you weren't a
Hispanic comic right you were like more
about just a comic yeah is Hispanic but
just just a comic yeah happens to be so
you also had a way addressing you
leather jacket use leather arc yet the
dark back then it didn't seem earthly it
just seemed like you were tired yeah
Gilbert has same thing oh it was because
of the lamp
okay he's like a doorman yeah yeah
Cricut the Cricut yeah look at the crack
okay he was he also you have to admit
this you were that got hottest guy at
the store well you know
weird I didn't feel that way when that
was all happening because Eleanor
recently tell me whisper out Eleanor
Carrigan
whisper whisper out she had so she goes
oh I think you were one of the top dudes
and you were you had some of the best
sets that were happening at that time
you were like you were like Dane Cook at
that time is so weird cuz I didn't look
at myself that way you were and maybe I
should have also I wanted to put your
powder name up
how much did Eleanor hate me back then
despised you crazy like how I mean I
just want to be dead
oh yeah I mean I could have to talk to
the two of them oh you were the mediator
yeah yeah I would
I'm friends with both of them on and
then I go talking to Bobby and then and
then she you know she'd be in the back
she'd walk by and just give a look that
Eleanor look that she don't know what
pissed me off the more vice versa she I
felt bad for Bobby because you know
Elroy I really really like her yeah like
it was probably warranted the way she
treated you seems like a really stand-up
woman straight and she doesn't take [ __ ]
from any Johnny defend me come on well
no because you guys hashed it out and
you got to defend me what was I one of
my like though good dude right I think
she was misinformed
there we go on that's that what really
happened here we go that's exactly a
misinformed Eleanor
because we had the but we did the
podcast together and you were explaining
you know she was getting information
from the phret of friends yeah and I
didn't even really know the whole thing
either to be honest with you you sort of
refreshed mmm I didn't I thought it was
about the dads so here's what Perry most
that's what you had gotten mad TV right
and we were coming into the store you
and I okay and there was a main room
show going on and Freddie Soto's wife
Korie and Eleonora were sitting there
watching the show and you as we walked
by them Cory says to you like why the
[ __ ] are you doing that show with that
piece of [ __ ]
and you said to her are you out of your
mind it's a [ __ ] TV show I've Bobby's
my friend you said that to her yeah and
I almost burst into tears and that's
when I knew that you were an ally for
life yeah now we're ready for this new
room
all right so you said you were gonna get
into the Vedic career that's going to
the reveal now what is what your need to
reveal all right
[Music]